eventually I just had to go so I went
down on my knees hunched down Palma
trousers down started going and couldn't
stop the Madagascar that I visited in
series 6 of extreme world is very
different from the one the Walt Disney
presented me with I got really ill when
I was there as sick as I was when I was
in Afghanistan when I had diarrhea and
vomiting for days and juggling around in
a vehicle when you're sick it's not
great you can't go to your mummy because
your mummys not there so a one point we
got to this village these guys never
seen white people quite surprised to see
us and we're quite bad luck in their
culture so you have to go and pay a
witch doctor in order to come in anyway
we got into the village we started doing
interviews about the raids that had in
the village up people were stealing the
careful anyway my stomach just went and
I knew I had to go and they don't have
toilets in the village because I think
it's bad luck and also for health
reasons so heads go to the back of the
village and couldn't find the toilet
eventually I just had to go so I went
down on my knees hunched down Palma
trousers down got my wet wipes out was
it wet watch your left pocket anyway
started going and couldn't stop but all
of a sudden no lady came out started
looking at me she was followed by an old
man then some kids then some other
grownups by the time I finished all
thought I'd finished at about thirty
people in the horseshoe around me so
anyway I get up I like haven't finished
so I have to go back down again and they
gave me a round of applause
in four days of juggling around
vehicle when you sick it's not great